humans have always searched for mythical
magical places
atlantis eldorado shangri-la but none of
them have actually been found besides
one
it started on a typical work day for me
when i was sifting through maps which
yes is something i routinely just do
paper maps digitized maps animated maps
i just can't get enough
so i'm sitting there looking through
some maps and i stumble upon this
this is a super old british map of north
america with a giant island off the west
coast
the island is labeled california
[Music]
okay so clearly some cartographer just
got this totally wrong and made a
mistake right
but wait
here's another
and another
and another
what is going on here this one's from
1785 or from 1750 this one's from 1690
and from 1650 like these maps of
california as an island are spanning
over 200 years
drawn by the dutch and the germans and
the british and the japanese everyone is
making a map showing california as an
island
is this like a tectonic plates thing
like was california an island because as
we dug we found thousands of these maps
california as an island everywhere
[Music]
i had to get to the bottom of this to
figure out what was going on here
luckily i live in washington dc so
there's somewhere i need to go visit to
figure this out
[Music]
hey in case anyone is in dc and is
looking for a nuclear fallout shelter i
found one
the library of congress
[Music]
[Music]
that's also my uh background as well
that map yeah yes
i love it it's just so beautiful
this puppy
wow
oh my god
so wait this is really weird i'm looking
at these original maps
1600s california is an island
but then look at this one
this is a map from like
a few decades earlier
and it shows california
accurately mapped earlier like decades
earlier in the 1500s they had it right
and it looks pretty accurate to the
california we know today and then
suddenly the whole world started mapping
california as an island
what
this is super weird
i vow now to figure out what the hell is
going on with california
[Music]
this first started as a nerdy history
cartography question
but soon we fell into a way deeper story
than we signed up for
the story of a mythical place called
california full of gold and magic and
dreams
fueled by people who weren't totally
grounded in reality
but rather in dreams of something bigger
something different
something that may or may not truly
exist
this island teaches us something bigger
than just how humans draw maps it's
actually more about how humans want to
see the world
about how fake ideas spread and why
so let me show you how for hundreds of
years california was an island and how
it still kind of is
[Music]
hey um wake up for a second do you mind
if i chat with you about something i
guess i make youtube videos
and in order to do that i have a
business that allows me to do that and
the business is from sponsorships and so
i'm making a video today that's
sponsored by a company called
storyblocks which is a company i've used
for like a decade even before they came
to sponsor video storyblocks is like a
massive library of visual and audio
assets that you can use to make your
videos better so creators of all size
small medium large giant creative teams
can subscribe to story blocks at
whatever budget or price point they need
and can have an unlimited library of
like 4k
amazing stock footage that is diverse
that is ever growing there's like
thousands and thousands of clips i use
this all the time for my videos one of
the big challenges for creators is that
it's really hard to go out into the
field and shoot stuff and so when you're
making a video you don't have a lot of
like really good visual assets with
storyblocks you literally have a
subscription to an unlimited amount of
amazing visuals and sound effects and
animation templates
it's a really freaking good deal in the
video i'm making right now it's about
maps of california and why california
used to be an island
you're gonna see like tons of storybox
footage that you won't even know
storybox footage but it is because i use
it all the time so anyway
thank you storybox for supporting this
video thank you for listening there's a
link in my description clicking that
link helps support this channel but it
also sends you to storybox so you can
check out their pricing plan find
something that fits your budget so now
i'm headed back to the studio to figure
out what the hell is going on with
california being mapped as an island
[Music]
one two three four five
okay this is california and this is baja
california which is a part of mexico and
this is the sea of cortez it's not a
full-blown sea it's actually a gulf the
gulf of california but we call it the
sea of cortez and you're about to find
out why i actually went here once when i
was a 19 year old mormon missionary
living in baja california for two years
anyway that is not important let's talk
about how this
became an island
california originally was an idea a myth
it was a fictional setting written into
this novel from 1510 in spain like 500
years ago california was like atlantis
or the garden of eden the author
described it as an island populated by
black women without any men existing
there on the entire island there was no
metal other than gold and it was ruled
by queen calafia hence california again
it was a fake place this is not a real
place this is a guy writing a novel
about a fake place but while the author
doesn't say exactly where this is he
basically says that it is quote at the
right hand of the indies reminder that
the indies is like over here in
southeast asia this novel was published
in spain about 50 years after the
invention of the printing press so
printed books were like a new technology
a big thing and this book was really
popular oh and by the way the book also
mentions that the women in california
these like women warriors were quote of
beautiful and robust bodies
so you have new technology books and
beautifully robust women basically click
bait for spanish sailors in the 1500s
they were out there exploring the world
and reading this book while they were
out to sea
oh and remember at this time these
spanish sailors are out exploring the
world that columbus had run into when he
was trying to find a quicker way to get
to asia
so it's like 10 years after columbus and
spain is sending people to explore the
new world and by exploring mean wink
wink extract resources and like destroy
the population and make spain rich and
one of those expeditions had this guy on
board hernan cortes he came over as a
young dude but he quickly became one of
the most shrewd aggressive like
detail-oriented colonizers that spain
had he goes on a big expedition where he
takes his 500 men and 16 horses to go
look for gold but cortes was secretly
harboring another goal for this
expedition he was reading the romance
novel that everyone else was reading and
he kind of wanted to find california the
fictional place in the book this would
be like some guy being out in like nepal
on a hike or something and he's like i
secretly want to find middle earth this
kind of reminds me when i was in wales
in 2011
and i like secretly wanted to find
hogwarts
like that kind of actually happened i
was young and i was like what if i
stumble upon hogwarts like i get it
cortez i get it you read it in the book
you're like this place is probably real
cortez a legitimate spanish explorer is
now looking for a fake place in a book
so cortez after he stumbles upon a great
civilization allies with their enemies
and destroys them with his guns and his
smallpox small side note that can be
covered in a different time he
eventually makes it over here oh by the
way cortez was kind of going rogue this
whole time he didn't have permission to
do this and the spanish leadership were
kind of freaking out
so much so that cortez had to write a
bunch of letters justifying how good all
of this conquest was anyway cortez sends
out a mission to go explore a little
further off this coast like around here
holy [ __ ] they found something
cortez is so giddy about this new
discovery that he writes a letter back
to the king saying that his men talked
to some natives
who quote affirm that there is an island
inhabited only by women and there are no
men that men come every once in a while
for them to like conceive but they only
keep the female children
it's only 10 days away
and that this island is very rich in
pearls
and
holy [ __ ]
[Music]
no men only women rich in gold
[Music]
and where does cortez think he is right
now
well back when the world looked like
this in these people's minds cortez is
just to the right of the indies
which is exactly the location described
in the book for california
cortez just discovered california
oh man this is amazing i i can feel the
excitement of cortez who literally has
spent years thinking about this island
and now he thinks he's found it
california but this is not what the king
of spain signed up for so the king of
spain is like no dude no we're not
looking for like mythical islands so he
cuts off all of the funding for any of
these like expeditions so cortes turns
to his own personal wealth and starts
funding these expeditions on his own to
go map out and find california the
island now i have to go to california he
personally goes on a voyage and starts
mapping and mapping and lo and behold
he's finding what looks like an island
and they set up a colony right here on
this island and they name the island
california after the island of queen
calafia from the book
okay okay okay spoiler alert remember
that cortez is like right here he's
looking up this massive gulf that he
thinks is like a full-blown sea that you
can like circumnavigate but he's just
like at the bottom of baja california
the peninsula and worst of all he's
burning his own cash to keep exploring
this california island idea he's got
california fever maybe the first but
definitely not the last to have it we're
going to california so cortez keeps
going and he's feeling really excited
he's like if this is an island then that
means that this sea probably extends up
and over the top of north america and
maybe there's a whole straight that goes
all the way back to spain making it
super easy for us to get between spain
and asia and so he keeps mapping and
mapping and mapping and
[Music]
oh no womp womp cortez ruined the myth
for everyone and he like wasted away a
bunch of his money in the process but
wait a minute this is like still the
beginning of the story like you see how
much longer is left in this video like
this isn't the story what's crazy is
what happens next because even though
cortez found out that california wasn't
an island this was all before this
happened
[Music]
and this is where the story gets very
juicy imho because somehow even after
all of this california still somehow
managed to make the world believe that
it was an island for hundreds of years
[Music]
okay so after the whole cortez
california dreaming incident spain went
on to ignore mapping california for a
very long time i mean they were really
busy conquering and destroying and
pillaging a lot of other places in the
region that is until the late 1500s
where they catch wind of a british
sailor who happens to be their literal
sworn enemy who apparently just landed
here in what was going to become oregon
to claim all of this land for britain
and spain was like oh [ __ ] we got to get
back in the game up there and that place
what was it called again cortez called
it like california after like from the
novel or something anyway let's get some
guys back up there to like map it out we
can't be asleep at the wheel while the
british are showing up on the west coast
of north america so they send out this
expedition of guys to go map the west
coast of california because after all if
you can map something you can conquer it
that's all they were thinking about here
was britain okay and this is where
things get so good all because of
another california dreamer this guy frey
antonio de la ascencion a spanish dude
who wasn't really a sailor or an
explorer or a cartographer he was kind
of like a catholic priest aboard this
expedition there were legit map makers
and fray antonio was literally the
assistant he had some knowledge of map
making but like he was literally the
plan b in case the main map maker died
his job was really just to be religious
boy did he do a lot more than that frey
antonio the peon assistant is actually
the most important person in this entire
story because he had an agenda he really
wanted spain to settle more aggressively
in california he felt the pull of
california this mythical cool place on
the west coast and it was his life's
mission to sell the idea of spain coming
to california and setting up more
permanent settlements no one on board
this expedition was on the same page
they were there just simply mapping the
west coast that's all they were doing so
they're going along this route fray
antonio's on the ship probably really
bored because he's literally not doing
anything he's looking overboard at this
land sort of in the distance and he
starts to see everything through his
lens of total bias this bias that
california was amazing and that spain
should settle it so they're passing like
right here on their way to the west
coast and fray antonio writes quote here
begins the entrance of the sea of
california which continues all the way
up north into this strait that actually
goes above north america and that if you
go you can find passage and navigation
to spain
wait what antonio you're sitting on the
side of a boat right here looking at
basically this and from that you've
deduced that california is an island and
that there's a passage above north
america that goes back to spain i swear
california does this to people it makes
them ignore reality in the name of a big
dream yet the thought of giving up
everything here and starting fresh in
california it's
it's so tempting and and exhilarating
that's the theme here happened to cortez
it's happening to fray antonio the guys
on the ship are like dude listen antonio
we get it you want spain to set on
california but that's not what this
mission is about we're here to map the
west coast of north america so just like
chill out and do your job sit around and
be religious and frey antonio like
continues to wax super nostalgic he's
like san diego is a very fine bay very
fine anchorage protected from all the
winds and undertow
like
anyway this expedition goes on to
fulfill its original purpose they map
the west coast of california and they
create this decent looking map but freya
antonio walked away from this mission
with a very different view he was
convinced that california was an island
and that there was a mythical northern
passage that existed all the way back to
spain and he was so audacious to say
quote i believe it will be necessary and
important to use what he's created what
he saw for revising and correcting the
existing maps of the earth since the
existing maps basically are very
different than what they are in fact
translation spain you need to change
your maps to what i saw when i was
sitting there bored looking over the
boat because california is an island i
mean the confidence in this guy is
astounding frantonio like makes a big
ruckus about this he tries to get spain
to change their maps to make california
island it got to the point where the
official map maker of spain had to
actually say
dude you're wrong he said quote since no
proof of the lake of gold or strait of
anion which is that northern strait
exists and since california has not been
circumnavigated little credit should be
given to these concepts like dude
frantonio your fake news you've been
debunked like give it up but frantonio
does not give it up for the next two
decades he continues to pitch his fake
version of california sending loads of
reports and maps of his version of
california what he saw all with the hope
that spain would catch on and come
settle california and he started to
actually gain some followers he was
pitching this he was like on a campaign
to like spread this idea that california
is an island i saw it with my own eyes
and this is where it gets crazy because
guess who enters the story but pirates
early 1600s is like the golden age for
pirates thousands of pirates were
sailing the seas and because spain was
like the best at like stealing stuff and
conquering places a spanish ship was
always like jackpot for the pirates one
such spanish ship was sailing back from
the new world to spain and on board this
ship was one of frey antonio's letters
with a copy of his fake map that showed
california as an island and the ship was
taken over by dutch pirates they took
the ship they steal all the stuff and
they stumble upon this bs fake map from
antonio like a deep fake of the map of
north america and the pirates are like
whoa look at this the spanish have
california as an island a little context
here maps back then were kind of a
national secret like they didn't share
maps very much so these dutch guys are
like holy [ __ ] we just discovered a big
spanish secret that california is an
island and that there's actually a
straight that goes over the top of north
america and they've been keeping it from
us the whole time so this map from
antonio gets back to the netherlands
which at the time were rising as like
really good map makers and sailors and
boom
a few years later the fake news just got
retweeted here it is this little map on
the cover page of some dutch atlas you
see for the first time california not
connected to the mainland but wait
cortez already mapped this and showed
that this wasn't an island like 100
years ago no what is happening the
answer is frey antonio and pirates the
myth was back shortly after that another
map pops up the dutch are slowly
adopting the idea of california as an
island and in true fake news form
everyone else was like well like the
dutch they're legit they said that
california is an island so i guess it is
word eventually spread to london where a
famous map maker made this map
wait a minute i know this map
this is the one that originally got me
interested in this whole entire topic
whoa hold on and now i finally
understand
what it says in this lower left
california sometimes supposed to be a
part of the western continent but since
by a spanish chart
taken by hollanders
it is found to be a goodly island
british cartographer verified account
retweets fray antonio's delusion and
suddenly this map with california as an
island is legitimized and starts to
spread like wildfire
seems legit says a dutch cartographer
boom retweet then to germany then to
france then to italy then to sweden and
turkey is now drawing california as an
island and austria is drawing california
as an island and now japan is drawing
california as an island retweet retweet
retweet
man where are the mods on this one who's
gonna fact check this
the entire globe now thinks that
california is an island and so yeah this
is how it happened lots of wishful
thinking a few crazy coincidences with
pirates the whole world thinks
california's an island for 200 years 200
years it's like several lifetimes all
because this one guy was obsessed with a
fake vision and he wouldn't let it go
now of course eventually explorers would
go and fact check this and debunk it and
maps slowly but surely start to phase
out california's in ireland but i want
to argue that this wasn't just freya
antonio and his wishful thinking i kind
of think that california does this to
people starting with cortez and
continuing to this day california has
continued to have a mythical pull on
people at least it has on european
people coming to california looking for
something magical looking for gold
eventually actually finding gold like
which is kind of insane to me that the
prophecy from a 1510 novel written in
spain kind of came true in 1849 when a
bunch of people found gold in california
as the local people who had been in
california for thousands of years were
exterminated and replaced by industrious
europeans california remained and
continues to be a place where people go
to dream big because palo alto is kind
of this mythical place where you know
all the startups come from like cortez
who spent all of his money trying to
like figure out what california was or
fray antonio who spent a good part of
his life trying to convince people that
california was an island something
special and ultimately it worked people
go to california to chase dreams that
usually aren't grounded in any sense of
reality you've been on the cover of
magazines you could transform healthcare
not only here in america but around the
world they go and they push and they
push and they push on some vision of
something new even when those dreams
rest on spreading disinformation to the
whole world was that too on the nose am
i stretching the analogy too much with
disinformation and propaganda and for
antonio and silicon valley like are you
getting this
i'll stop the point is that to me this
is the beauty and the peril of
california as a place yeah it's attached
to the continent we all know that but
california kind of is an island
ecologically it has thousands of totally
unique species of flora and fauna that
don't exist anywhere else economically
it's the fifth biggest economy on earth
and culturally i mean california is its
own culture and the result is that today
people still do what those guys were
doing in the 15 1600s coming west to
california to chase dreams to chase gold
to chase something new in that sense
california is an island frantonio was
right the whole time
okay see ya
[Music]
you